well now that I know that that the show
is going what what were we talking about
because I was interested if we could go
take a step back yeah what were we
talking about we're talking about Beryl
bill burr you were talking about Oh
welcome to the bill burr recovery yeah I
went into therapy after that episode I'm
not even really I'm not even being
kidding I mean I was I was having a
depressive episode for a long time right
and I had these antidepressants next to
my bed for a long time and not taking
them no I hadn't decided to take them
yet
I was hesitant yeah and after that
episode bill burr I came home and I
that's when I started taking and I
pressed antidepressants that I went to
therapy Wow
it was soul-crushing and II was it so
concern because you felt like as an
interviewer it was so crushing or
disliked as it on a human level like do
you think do you know the levels where
it felt that it hits you right um
everything man my my fans were I don't
know a fan but audience were very harsh
as an interviewer I felt like a failure
it was just off it wasn't you know it
wasn't it didn't feel that bad but it
was the reaction the audience reaction
to it afterwards I mean I knew I had
goofed up and that it was not the best
interview and I was such a big fan of
Bilborough obviously whoo yeah he's he's
a legend and you just in your mind have
high hopes that you'll be able to yeah I
get something good at ya there's
expectations yeah alike but the that
that there was people making like video
essays about how what a terrible you
know interviewer I am really that's best
YouTube style that's kind of stuff I'm
somewhat used to but yeah that just felt
I just it felt like a rock bottom for me
because I was having a hard time with
the podcast and interviews in general
and that for me was just kind of like
the culmination of a lot of Oh dress oh
that's interesting so it was like so in
hindsight though does it almost feel
like it was it was supposed to happen
like it was like oh I needed something
that you kind of made me look at stuff
or just gave me like a moment to reflect
well I definitely needed something to
push me because taking antidepressants
going to therapy was like the best
I said were made for me and my family
and professionally - I mean it's made
everything better
really so I mean if it wasn't that it
would be something else but but that was
like a little bit of somehow it was part
of a catalyst it was it was a few that
alignment yeah yeah it was it was that
and I had him on a second time somewhat
recently and it went great so I'm happy
to hear that yeah he reached out he said
he wanted to do it I was like blast dude
let's go there's like Fear Factor for me
round two yeah everyone my life the
first time let's go and yeah that's
interesting yeah it was a yeah when he
came in here was a strange experience
man it was I don't know I just felt like
he was a different person
not on podcasts and he was on podcast
it's almost like but then also I didn't
really know him that great and so maybe
I just don't know how people are that's
true I wonder if he listens to these
probably not oh I mean I doubt he
doesn't mean everybody's busy yeah he's
he doesn't care what we think about him
I listen to some of those murder things
you know where people get murdered some
guy walking into the woods in the Joshua
tree and [ __ ] never came out and how
do you hear that there's a podcast of
those like missing people or something
do you feel like that when you talk
about Bill burr like a missing person
like oh I felt like it was a couple
minutes afterwards I was just kind of
wandering around you know but I don't
know I just you know I did not know him
that good let me ask you is when you
guys end it I mean it was it was clearly
you knew it wasn't going well during or
was it when you started the Reno I knew
that there was something uncomfortable I
didn't know if I didn't know I thought
for a second like maybe I was going
crazy you're always like Vietnam you're
getting in your head you're what's going
on well it's just an uncomfortable most
like oh well he and I obviously there's
only so much time that we probably one
of the reasons maybe we don't talk that
much is because we mind if I take these
off no it's fine it's because we
shouldn't talk that much you know
so I just thought here's a guy who is
very he's exactly what I thought when I
if I really would have looked at it oh
here's a guy who maybe this is exactly
the way he is onstage there's not a way
for her there's no real difference you
know it's just he's just rambling kind
of like if he's unhappy he's unhappy and
he you know eternally disgruntled bright
he's kind of uh you know guy who's kind
of fighting against his own probably ill
wills and [ __ ] looks like all of us are
in some weird ways but for him maybe
it's like a just a different battle and
also that he he likes to that he's the
center of attention a lot I think and so
it's he pub he might not be able to
really notice when how other people are
feeling or reacting that's kind of the
vibe that I got at the end and right so
the thing is that I feel like most
guests 99% of guests there they're more
gracious you know they won't take the
opportunity if they see you like are
uncomfortable or you give up or maybe
you said like when he sees an opening he
will he like attacks yeah you know what
I mean
and it's assembly his comedy yeah and
that's why he's so good at comedy but
like he he is unlike anyone else I've
ever interviewed because the second time
when I interviewed him I really just
like talked as little as I possibly
could yeah and that and that was been
the best but you you obviously have to
handle each interview differently but he
was unlike anyone I had ever interviewed
because yeah and I don't even really
interview he was one like it one like
why finish a sentence at a time because
he is because he's not willing to give
you the benefit of the doubt you know
what I mean and he will he will expose
any chinks in her armor yeah cuz for him
that's comedy right right he's gonna
make a moment out of it for me I'm like
ah [ __ ] my fragile ego and yet for me I
think I'm used to I think I'm I'm good
at rip on people if that's what we're
doing I think I'm right I knew what we
were doing yeah I think it's like a
roller skates to a [ __ ] sword that's
funny you know yeah that's good that's a
good so I think um because in previous
conversations I had with them it had
been
more of a communication about kind of
real stuff that was going on in my
career right questions I had you know
and I come it was kind of looking up to
him I think also in some way for me as a
role model mm-hmm you know and when you
get when you get a certain response from
someone you have expectations on in your
own mind they for me when I get a
response to them that they don't they
don't realize that I see them that way
or it doesn't matter to them or whatever
and that's fine it's his own world I
built up in my head for some reason that
hits harder a little bit you know or it
like it's just a weird or dent but for
me also it's just like I'm not even a
[ __ ] interviewer dog you know I'm
saying like I don't know what I'm doing
are you doing our best but I was just
happy to sit down with him yeah his
[ __ ] I think maybe we sat down maybe
on the wrong day maybe we started you
know I don't know but stuff we were
talking about off the podcast when I
brought it up on the podcast it was like
we've never spoken off the podcast and
that seemed very weird to me I had this
same reaction to him but like you made
this joke about do you have a do you
have a gun in your helicopter but he
just I don't know why he took that so
the wrong way oh yeah that's just a
funny I mean I mean it was a funny
premise yeah I think at that point I had
also at some point I'd kind of checked
out I think yeah you know I think I was
kind of but you you said to me that you
don't want to do guess anymore I'm doing
know I'm doing less guest:is I had the
same reaction to I was canceling
episodes after that oh no I was I needed
to cancel this is way before that I was
trying to can't pare down we were just
trying to lie just too much stress what
do you mean what's stress about what
this year I just hit a level is just too
much stress for me good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one